Freunde wir befinden uns in Köln am
Heumarkt for servus Colonia Alpina denn
das hier ist das Lieblingsrestaurant von
Mark Eggers und ich bin sehr sehr froh
dass du das Restaurant ausgewählt hast
ich kenne sie war schon einmal da was
macht das für dich besonders als Kölner
geht man natürlich in so ein bayerisches
österreichisches Restaurant passt
eigentlich gar nicht aber ich finde es
ultra gemütlich ich mag auch sehr gerne
die Küche ja so Schnitzel und Spätzle
und sowas und da kriegt man auf jeden
Fall sehr gut was geboten
dementsprechend für mich macht's aber
auch die Atmosphäre da dran ja das wird
man gleich sehen es ist wirklich hübsch
wir gehen mal gemeinsam rein suchen uns
einen schönen Platz und dann gibt es vor
allem was leckeres zu essen weil ich bin
mir sicher du hast ein gutes Restaurant
ausgeht schauen wir mal rein
[Musik]
ich hatte heute nur so eine instant
Pudding Ball mit zwei Proteinpulver du
machst jetzt richtig auf Fitness ja seit
einem Monat aber heute werden wir uns
also beim nächsten Mal gehen wir dann in
unserem Halsey wir wollen
ich hole mir immer diese geile
Käseplatte wie viel diesmal ja jedes Mal
also wirklich und ich liebe es auch
immer so zu teilen ich liebe eigentlich
Restaurants wo jeder so ein bisschen was
bestellt also Tapas ist so mein
lieblings Ding eigentlich weil jeder
kann so ein bisschen mal hier
reingreifen und so und dann gibt's
natürlich das Schnitzel für mich geil
jetzt kommt's aber mit Spätzle
also komplett low carry Option ich
zerschieß mich heute komplett die Figur
ich muss überlegen ob ich genau das
gleiche nehme oder was anderes aber das
klingt schon sehr sehr gut muss ich
sagen also wer dann noch mal so ein 42
km Marathon laufen kannst und das dann
alles zu verbrennen
kleiner Blick mal in die Karte was ist
hier ungefähr gibt wir haben oberster
das ist ja ein bayerischer Klassiker
Rösti spanfer Rinderroulade Spareribs
Wiener Kalbsschnitzel Krusten
Schinkenbraten also es ist so richtig
deftiges Essen eher so in die alpine
Richtung
und ich bin sehr sehr traurig darüber
sonst immer gerne das kann ich jetzt
einfach nachholen solidarisch nachholen
Rinderroulade ist auch sehr gut drin ich
muss bei meinen Schlüssel bleiben ich
war leider lange nicht mehr hier gewesen
weil ich so viel unterwegs war auf der
Schnitzel mit Preise werden gibt das so
sehr gut aber es gibt auch nichts
geileres du fährst Ski oder Snowboard
Kerst dann einen so eine geile Berghütte
und gut dir dann wirklich Kaiserschmarrn
am Ende noch und so ich würde Zero
nehmen bitte jetzt kommt ein Doodler hey
ich bin hier richtig drin in der Thema
wie immer
klassischer Typ 20 mal im Restaurant und
20 Mal dasselbe ja ich bestehe so selten
ich liebe das eigentlich neue Sachen zu
probieren und finde das toll aber ich
bin immer derselbe Typ ich finde gerade
wenn man Hunger du meinst gegessen ist
so die Akzeptanz für Experimente ganz
geringen ich würde diese Käseplatte
einmal nehmen
aber mit Spätzle ich nehme bitte die
Rinderroulade ich finde die knusprige
Ente ein Viertel es ist bestellt
da haben wir hier einmal die das ist
eine viertel Ente
oh das mag egal
was für ein Bild hübsches essen also
wirklich alle
Speisen ich bin gar nicht so ein Typ der
so Stories oder Fotos machen von essen
aber ich wusste nicht wie sehr ich Lust
auf das Essen
[Musik]
guten Appetit wir probieren einfach
parallel wir haben einfach beide zu
großen Hunger so lange nicht gegessen
hat meine Mom früher immer gemacht Alter
ich bin gespannt was du zum Schnitzel
sagt ja ich bin gespannt was du zurück
oder sagst ja vielleicht bestelle
erweitere ich deinen bestell Repertoire
hier
und die Spätzle sind auch wirklich zehn
von zehn das ist so mein Essen nein
diese deutsche Küche ist geil man
schmeckt richtig die ist schön frisch
gemacht ich finde das Restaurant ist ein
richtiges Überraschungspaket wir waren
ja gerade davor ich habe das Äußere
gesehen das Innere ist wunderschön und
das Essen überzeugt auch also wirklich
eine super Auswahl die du getroffen hast
für mich kann gar nicht so viel dafür ne
ich habe wieder gekocht man sonst was
noch ist mein Restaurant aber ich gehe
hier gerne hin fühlt sich schon so als
hättest ich probiere jetzt mal hier vom
Schnitzel wenn das okay ist auf jeden
Fall ist es auch schön so friert ne kein
Problem
wenn wir letzte Woche viel über
Schnitzel gelernt man sieht es ist nicht
ganz so dünn sage ich jetzt mal wie beim
Grubert aber es ist wirklich ein
verdammt gut Schnitzel knusprig schön
buttrig so du bist aber auf jeden Fall
so ein richtig herzhafter Fernseher
schmecken super gut Schnitzer hat echt
in sich muss jetzt gleich noch mal
gelblichen von den Spätzle mir
genehmigen ja ja die sind auch richtig
gut danach bist du satt ne das ist eine
ganz mächtige Nummer machen
also mit einem U12 vielleicht der Teller
und jetzt einmal die Schmerzen
käsefäden die sich davon ziehen wirklich
sehr sehr krass man schmeckt das ist
nicht so ein
standard-industriekehle sondern schon
was kerniges Wasser auch mit drin
richtig gekocht auf jeden Fall so eine
Platte ist einfach cool zwischendurch ne
ja bis dann da noch Abwechslung macht
das richtig geil
vielen Dank doch doch danke schön das
ganze Essen alles was probiert habe
Schnitzel das beste Schokolade Klöße ist
genauso wie man sich wünscht richtig
schön deftig aus Manns kostet
meine Ente schmeckt auch sehr sehr
lecker ich habe die gerade hier mal
angeschnitten ist schon relativ durch
muss man sagen aber dafür habe ich auch
diese Bratensoße bekommen die wirklich
auch sehr sehr lecker ist ich mache
immer so jedes Jahr so eine
Weihnachtsfeier mit meinem ganzen
Freunden und dieses Jahr werden wir die
hier verbringt tatsächlich im servus
reserviert wahrscheinlich oder wir haben
schon mal anklingen lassen das ist zur
Weihnachtszeit hier sehr laut werden
kann Weihnachtsfeier
bezieht sich auch nicht so sehr aus
Essen und noch mehr raus trinken aber da
kommen wir auch hin weil es einfach auch
vom Ambiente herstellen ist und so das
ist glaube ich auch noch mal für die
Weihnachtsfeier auch noch mal eine
schöne Lokalität hast du sonst noch
Restaurants die du so richtig gut
findest hier in Köln hol die Döner
ich bin wirklich gerne bei Noah ich
mache sehr gerne die Nudeln mit den
Spitzen wirklich super super lecker ja
das ist jung heißt alles über Holz
gegrill
sein soll gerne natürlich und Pancho
hier auch in der Salzgasse was ist deine
Nummer eins für Dates Griffin
aber wenn du ein bisschen auf Eindruck
machen willst und jetzt kommt natürlich
aber immer auf die Begleitung an ne es
gibt auch Frauen die fühlen sich da
nicht so wohl dann ist es nicht die
beste Adresse aber so wenn du schon der
Darm auch signalisieren willst du hast
dir Gedanken gemacht und gibst dir
wirklich Mühe Wiest absolute das Essen
natürlich auch super ich würde sagen wir
kämpfen uns ja mal jetzt auf ganz
entspannt durch Essen super lecker
nettes Gespräch wie immer mit dir und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder also
welche Bewertung würdest du meinen
Liebling ich würde halt auch wenn das
Restaurant schlecht gewesen wäre was es
nicht ist dann würde ich von meinem
Charakter hier niemals sagen hey das war
jetzt eine fünf von zehn aber es war
auch keine fünf von zehn sondern es war
eine ehrliche achteinhalb neun die
Sachen waren richtig gut ausgeführte
Version von geilen Klassikern im schönen
Ambiente ist ein richtig gutes
Restaurant
und wenn jetzt gleich noch der Haselnuss
Schnaps kommt dann wird es vielleicht
noch eine Minute ja mag vielen Dank dass
wir das heute drehen konnten es war
wirklich ein eine Freude wie immer mit
dir wirklich mag auch hinter der Kamera
einer der sympathischsten die ich kenne
Kuss auf die wirklich wahr wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
macht's gut schaut unbedingt beim Markt
vorbei Ciao Daumen nach oben geben
abonnieren nicht vergessen und schreibt
in die Kommentare mit welcher Person
soll er denn demnächst mal das
Lieblingsessen ja fast vergessen
mich würde interessieren in Baden-Baden
wo geht man da essen was ist das
Liebling von Jena
cool finden statt